- Ch-che-kwilio?
- [Voiceover] Are you serious?
- Shut the (beep) up, Caitlin.
(latin music)
- My disclaimer is that
there is like a gene
in my family for being bad at languages.
- I went to Spain this summer.
- I took only French.
- I'm hoping I don't
embarrass myself too much.
- [Voiceover] Een-ya-ree-too.
- Uh, I have absolutely no
clue how to pronounce this.
- There's already, like, three hats
on top of these letters that I don't know.
- In-ah-rih-too.
- In-ah-roo-tee? In-ah-roo, In-a, Inn...
- In-ya-ree-too.
- Ooh, I didn't roll the "r" enough.
Een-ya-rree-too.
- 'Cause in America, you
can't say anything correctly.
You just say it anyways.
- [Voiceover] Peh-nya nyeh-toe.
- Oh, don't make me butcher
the president's name.
- So, like, I should probably know that.
- It looks like it's penne.
- Penne nay-oh-toe, penne nay-oh-toe.
No (laughs), I just said the same thing.
- Pee-nah?
What the (beep) is "e" again?
Is it like an "i" or an "a" or what is it?
- [Voiceover] Ah-yeer-ah-gah-rye.
- There's so many letters in this word.
- There's way too many "g's" and "r's".
- Oh my god, this poor
kid in elementary school.
Name was probably butchered all the time.
- The first part of it
looks like Aguilera.
- Ag (laughs) ag-yoo-ehrgh ehrgh (laughs).
- Ag-ah-ree-gah-reh-reh.
- Ah-goo-gah-ray?
- Ah-geh-rah, gah-reh, ah-geh-rah-gah-reh?
- Ah-gah-ree-gah-reh.
- Irr-reh-gar-ay?
- How do you say it?
- [Voiceover] Vahl-dehr-rrah-mah.
- I know this one, That 70's Show.
- Vahl-der-ma-ma.
- Vahl-dehr-rrah-mah.
- Vahl-du-rhama, rh, rha-mah.
- [Voiceover] Say-ah-choe-kay.
- This looks like a shoe
brand or something like that.
Sie-shi?
- Shah-shoe? Oh man.
See-ah-choo-koo?
- Saw-she-koo? (laughs)
Wait no, no, no, no.
- See-ah-coe-que?
- See-ah-cho-kay?
I just get images of somebody
being choked. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] Ech-ay-ver-ee-ah.
- [Voiceover] This is a sexier name.
- I feel like this is a
really expensive water.
Etch-ee-ah-very-ay?
- Ech-i-veria.
- Ech-i-reh...(laughs)
- I never judge people
who have thick accents.
I'm always like, "Dude, I get it."
I just wanna say that for the record.
- Hopefully I wouldn't offend
someone if I said their name.
- [Voiceover] Zuluaga.
- These are Spanish, really?
- Zoo-laga?
Oh, the Z's silent?
- Zoo-lah, Zoo-lah-ga?
- Zulu-lagah. (laughs)
- Zulu-agah.
I'm getting images of like Fabio but Latin
for some reason. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] Palazuelos.
- Pah-lah-zulus?
- Pah-lah-zay-loos?
- Palazuelos.
- Pah-lah-swe-los.
Everyone's so excited, 'cause I proved
that I'm not a complete moron.
- I felt like the substitute
teacher who, you know,
can't pronounce anybody's name.
- It was a massacre.
There's, like, no excuse.
- All of them are very sexy.
- Latin America, I'm sorry.
If it makes you feel
better, I'm not much better
with English names.
(laughs) The audio
department's laughing at me.
The director's laughing at me.
Save your comments.
I already got all the heat
when it actually happened.